how's the gum raised my spirit back
welcome back to fuzz rag we're gonna
have some fun today I love ass hmm we're
both simple I noticed me oh my god I
found the best thing ever
yeah yeah yeah what's happening I like
cold
I like booty had me like my my name is
Eva and could you please put your
meatballs in my mouth yeah oh god it's a
potato slice trying to get out my mouth
Thomas ah how oh let me just cut to the
chase can I lick yo there Oh God I'm a
poet you want me to lick your lips my
name is Danny I like to lick [ __ ] yeah
oh god what the [ __ ] back it up back it
like a my tongue Becky see if you can
catch it ah not to let ha ha ha ha
this is how a hit on ladies
when I see a hot chick yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah la la la la there's an
ice cream stick coming out of my mouth
oh I'm doing okay whenever I see someone
I don't really like that's disturbing my
anaconda don't my anaconda don't want
none unless you got sweet iced buns hon
oh you gotta have them sweet oh okay
give me that sweet Oh Oh just thinking
about that is just makes me oh oh oh my
god it's a dais it's a tan it's sad it's
sad a Bullock whatever I see food that I
really like all right try again yeah ha
ha ha
it's a decade oh my god whenever I see a
sweet-ass booty oh my god that mouth hi
oh you're never gonna get a boyfriend
back here you know that right you're fat
and ugly Becky I come on don't cry Becky
it's not my fault I'm beautiful no what
I look delicious
is there something wrong you wouldn't
want to eat me just cuz I don't have a
tongue I'm better than that McDonald's
[ __ ] Maine you gotta stop kidding away
made McDonald's why why do you cheat on
me with McDaniels at least tell me it
was Burger King
I need to stop by I'm so childish
why so childish my guess is serious
business pants God says if that won't
help me seriously blame me man I can't
don't my anaconda don't my anaconda
don't want none unless you got buns hun
boy toy named Troy used to live in
Detroit
what's he shoot up with the law but he
live in the palace but me Alexander
McQueen and he will keeping me stylish
now that real real real bar fight it's
so bad
look at her but I friends got over there
in that episode there hope you bros
enjoy watching if you did as always
thanks for leaving like I really
appreciate it
stay awesome bud